as the campaign heats up joe biden
stumbling and bumbling begins to bite
him the biden campaign dumps a
scurrilous covedad on the trump
administration
and we tell the amazing story of a fake
native american bisexual professor
who didn't die of covid i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today with
expressvpn.com go check them out
expressvpn.com
alrighty so before we begin just got a
note you don't want to be spending as
much money as you're currently spending
on your cell phone bill
and you don't want to be spending a lot
of money on anything right now because
who the hell knows where the economy is
going so why would you be spending
up to twice as much money as you
normally should on your cell phone bill
maybe more than that maybe hundreds of
dollars a month
on your cell phone bill the average
person is saving 400 a year on their
wireless bill by switching
to puretalk usa who is your wireless
provider att verizon t-mobile what if i
told you that pure talk usa
uses the exact same coverage as one of
those carriers same tower same exact
coverage
but literally will cost you half the
price how do they make it so affordable
well
there are no retail stores no low
overhead so
so low overhead and you're not funding
their billion dollar ad campaigns you're
only paying for the data you need
no contract no excessive fees you'll
enjoy unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data all for just
20 a month it's a great way to save
money grab your mobile phone dial pal in
and say ben shapiro when you do you get
250 bucks off any iphone including the
brand new iphone
s8 again that is pound 250 say keyword
ben shapiro to get started save yourself
all sorts of money on your cell phone
bill you don't need unlimited data what
you do need
is a lower cell phone bill go check them
out pound 250 and say keyword ben
shapiro to get started with my friends
over at puretalk
okay so before i begin you may have
noticed that we've changed venue a
little bit the reason we've changed
venue
is for the same reason my voice sounds a
little bit different today i got a bit
of a cough got a bit of a cold
and so i had a covered test yesterday
i'm waiting for the results in the
meantime i am isolating
here in casa de shapiro and uh
when i find out what's going on then i
will head back into the office when i'm
clean and
no longer a danger to others around me
okay so just want to make that
brief note so you know what the hell is
going on meanwhile i'm not the only one
relegated to my basement joe biden
continues to be relegated to his
basement the big problem for joe biden
is that he is falling apart he is he's
just falling apart it is perfectly
obvious to anyone
any sentient human being with a
functioning pair of eyes in a prefrontal
cortex that joe biden is not even what
he used to be
and let's face it joe biden used to be
not that great so he's even less great
now
joe biden is is just mentally inept
he is he he can't string sentences
together anymore
he sounds like he sounds like a normal
person after they've had
a bunch of ambien and that is what joe
biden sounds like and this is not due to
the fact that he had
a stutter when he was younger he
overcame that what we are seeing now
is is simply age manifest it doesn't
mean that
he's completely senile it does mean that
his faculties have begun to degrade you
can see it in real time
and he says weird thing after a weird
thing so far does not come back to bite
him
because donald trump is so volatile that
all biden has to do is basically point
to trump but
as we see more and more abiding there
are going to be serious questions to be
asked and if trump can somehow
hold himself together for more than five
seconds a lot of the focus in this
campaign is gonna shift
to joe biden in fact there's some pretty
good poll numbers suggesting that the
race is tightening even this early
and i say this early i mean it's still
kind of early right i mean it's
beginning of august we haven't had
conventions or anything yet
biden's real clear politics polling
average is now
only six points up he's only six six and
a half points up on donald trump
okay well just a couple of weeks ago
that looked a lot more like
nine or ten points in fact in three of
the last four national polls
donald trump is within striking distance
namely three or four points of joe biden
according to new hill harris poll
biden is up only three nationally 43-40
and if he's up 43-40
trump wins the election really because
trump is going to do better than 40.
and if biden stuck down at 43 that looks
very much like a lot of the polls
that that hillary clinton had going into
2016 where she was getting like 44
of the vote and trump was at 39. there
there are a couple numbers to watch one
is the gap
the other is the fact that biden seems
unable to break 50
in nearly any poll he's having real
trouble breaking 50 percent in the last
few polls
he's down around 47 48 trump will finish
somewhere up around 45
he will okay so you've got the hill
harris pole then you have a rasmussen
pole that shows biden up 4845
and you have an emerson pole showing
biden up 50 to 46.
in all of those donald trump is
significantly within striking distance
now in the swing states now biden is
leading in
all the swing states at this point but
it is also true
that trump is within striking distance
in a lot of those swing states
he's within about four in north carolina
he's within about four in florida he's
within about five
in pennsylvania he's within three in
arizona he needs to win a lot of those
states
but could it happen sure especially
again if the focus begins to shift to
biden speaking of which so
joe biden over the last 48 hours he's
just fallen all over himself
so he was doing an interview with the
national association of black
journalists
and he just randomly decided that he was
going to say
that all black people think alike unlike
latino people
i'm like latino people who are quite
diverse black people all think like
here is joe biden falling all over
himself
what you all know but most people don't
know
unlike the african-american community
with notable exceptions
the latino community is an incredibly
diverse community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
so that's wild okay like really if
donald trump went out there and he's
like
all the black people they think the same
and they like look the same and uh
everybody's like well what what that now
donald but joe biden's out there being
like
latinos are very diverse and very
diverse unlike black people who are not
diverse at all they'll
kind of are thinking the same okay so
that guy is not with us
joe biden is not with us and it's it's
literally every other word that comes
out of his mouth is incoherent
i mean yesterday again national
associate of black national association
of black journalists
here he is just stumbling all over
himself again and this is like a regular
thing
i'm so forward-looking to have an
opportunity to sit with
the president or stand with the
president and debates
there can be plenty of time and by the
way as i joke with them you know
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
something i don't i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental fil
my physical as well as my mental fitness
guys he's super happy to have the
american public judge his physical and
mental fullness
illness
[Music]
that guy is who the democrats chose he
is very lucky right now
that he is basically in the basement
because if this person were out there on
the campaign trail
this would be all the footage wall to
wall all the time
and then he botched his own china policy
so again it's not like he's doing this a
little bit he's doing it pretty much
every single thing he says
here was joe biden yesterday botching
his own china policy
the way trump the way china will respond
is when we gather the rest of the world
that in fact invades and and free in
in open trade and making sure that we're
in a position that the world
that we deal with who the right way
that then in fact that's when things
began to change
that's when china that's when uh china's
behavior is going to change
he's not speaking english guys he is not
speaking english and it is perfectly
fair to point this out because
what it really means is that whoever he
picks is his vp is going to be president
and we can fairly assume that within a
couple of years job i mean if he's
declined this much just over the course
of the campaign and he has
then who is going to be effectually be
the president it ain't going to be biden
that is not an absurd contention nor is
it an ageist contention
he is just not fully there there are
plenty of people who are 80 who are
fully there
joe biden is declining he's in his
listen i had a violin teacher when i was
younger he was 80 years old his name was
abram stern fantastic fantastic teacher
he was with it he was sharp
i have a grandmother who's 89 she's with
it she is sharp
she's much more with it than joe biden
is right now no question
and how not with it is joe biden again
if you just reversed the parties he'd be
getting ripped up and down for the kind
of crap that spews out of his mouth on a
regular basis yesterday
he asked a black journalist from cbs
news if he was a junkie
not joking a thing that happened in real
life
please clarify specifically have you
taken
a cognitive no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program if you
take a test where you're taking cocaine
or not what do you think huh
are you a job what do you say to
president trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters are you a junkie
look at that crazy ass caesar romero
joker smile
pasted on that grill my goodness my
goodness
well it's no wonder that many medical
professionals are wondering about what
they are seeing
in joe biden and don't give me the you
don't get to speculate from afar on his
medical condition i'm not speculating on
his medical condition i'm just telling
you what i see in front of my very own
eyes
okay this didn't work for hillary
clinton when she tried to claim that she
was totally fine and then collapsed into
a van
it certainly is not going to work for
democrats whistling past the graveyard
no pun intended with joe biden with joe
biden going around basically pretending
he's perfectly fine and we can all see
that he is
basically bumping into the furniture
there's a doctor named mark siegel he's
on fox he's on with sean handy last
night he said
joe biden should probably have some sort
of diagnostic assessment because this
does not
look particularly good
again i can't diagnose him over a video
camera but when he was talking about
those two animals he wasn't even talking
about the president he was talking about
a cnn anchor
that made that mistake that shows
wandering i've made my career about not
diagnosing
remotely but i'm concerned about a lot
of the things i'm seeing and i feel more
towards the president's point that it's
fair game
it's something that's fair game if these
tests aren't done
then then the voters have to decide
right but i think it's right to have an
assessment now we had a medical
examination in december
a full medical examination but this was
not addressed at that time sean
yeah again he seems to be falling apart
we're gonna get to more of joe biden in
just a second
the fact that he's falling apart is
allowing him to avoid the actual
blame for the stuff that he's saying i
mean saying that all black people think
the same way all latino people do not
it's
pretty racist it really is i mean i
don't know what he thinks he is saying
there but
it's pretty incredible that he said it
out loud and then everybody's like okay
well that's just just that's the show
being senile
okay either his senility is a point in
his favor or does a point against him
you cannot have it both ways
he'll get some more of this in just one
second first we all hear stories
in the news where a good guy uses a gun
to protect his family from criminals
then he's the one arrested
in fact we just saw this happen in
missouri where a couple
tried to defend their property by
bringing guns outside their property and
then they were
essentially they were essentially hit
with criminal charges
the legal system is not fair when it
comes to governors very often and
responsibly armed americans often become
political targets
it's not right that responsible
americans can wind up in jail or tied up
in a lawsuit for defending themselves or
their family but in this day and age you
need a gun to protect your family and
yourself
here's how you can take a simple
powerful journey to firearms
and self-defense confidence it's called
the complete concealed carry and family
defense guide
from the united states concealed carry
association it is 100
free you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting
the safest and most dangerous places to
sit in a restaurant how to responsibly
own and store a gun particularly if you
have little kids like i do and a whole
lot more it's 164 pages
it comes the bonus audio version so you
can listen whenever you want just text
ben
to 87222 again just just text ben my
name to 87 222 you'll get instant access
and a chance to win a thousand bucks
so you can buy a gun to protect your
family text pen to eight seven two two
two right now that's
text bend to eighty seven two two two
and join my friends at this concealed
carry
association alrighty so good news for
biden
is that biden gets to continue hiding in
the basement he has announced that he is
not
ever going to leave the basement
originally he was scheduled to fly to
wisconsin
to accept the party nomination now he's
not going to no one else
will go to milwaukee he's instead going
to just stay in his basement and accept
the nomination from there which again
makes sense he's he's basically playing
prevent defense here
is joe biden it's not like he has a
great offense here joe biden's entire
campaign is i'm not trump and i'm also
barely alive
so staying in the basement serves him
perfectly well
it is hilarious watching nancy pelosi
say the reason that biden is staying
home is because he's so serious about
kova it's because
because he's so serious about covert
that seems somewhat unlikely to me i
mean biden could certainly do a socially
distant speech in milwaukee
he's staying at home because it's very
comfortable at home
and it means that he never has to leave
the basement or ask or answer any
significant questions here is nancy
pelosin here is nancy pelosi densures a
clackan
oh i think that uh i'm we're all
learning this at the same time now
that he won't be there but i think it's
an indication
of the seriousness that she uh judges
the
uh the situation this pandemic is is
dangerous and the increase in numbers uh
just demands
uh that we keep our distances i commend
him for doing that it's going to be a
great convention
yes i'm sure that that's exactly what's
going to happen i'm sure i'm sure that
it's all about the pandemic and it has
nothing to do with the fact
that joe biden is perfectly comfortable
staying out of the limelight and letting
trump
have his own way with the limelight
meanwhile president trump is campaigning
against biden and he is correct he says
listen joe biden is going to be
whatever they tell him to be joe biden
is not in control of himself he's not in
control of this campaign
and he is not in control of the
democratic party platform here is trump
going after biden yesterday
joe biden's whatever they tell him to be
and i think it's
good that a wife is i would expect a
wife to say that that's the
appropriate thing to say but joe is
being taken so far left look at the
manifesto that he and bernie agreed to
that's further left than bernie ever was
okay and trump is exactly right about
all of this mike pence did a speech
yesterday
in which he went after biden with
alacrity as well pointed out that joe
biden wants a 1 trillion
tax increase in a time of economic
crisis which is pretty much the worst
idea ever here was
the vice president going after joe biden
i mean in the midst of a pandemic
joe biden would raise taxes by a
trillion
dollars
the contrast president donald trump cut
taxes for the american people and we're
going to keep fighting for tax
relief for the american people for four
more years
more broadly pence is saying that biden
is going to set us on a path toward
socialism and decline
now here's the thing the trump campaign
basically has to make a two-step
argument when it comes to
joe biden step number one dude's not in
control of himself step number two
the people who are in control are the
people who are radical the good news for
them is that biden is providing evidence
of that every day and whoever he selects
his as his vp pick is going to go a long
way toward opening a door for
republicans
this is why i think his smart pick is
probably susan rice she appears
somewhat more moderate in public than
for example a communist like karen bass
she's not nearly as off-putting as
kamala harris i think it'll probably end
up being susan rice if i had to
put money on it but with that said
whoever he selects whomever
biden selects is likely to become the
focal point of the campaign pence says
listen biden is going to set us on a
path toward socialism and decline
and he's not going to be a bulwark in
favor of any of the values of capitalism
or americanism that america historically
has stood for
because the truth is joe biden and the
radical democrats would set america on a
path of socialism and decline
president trump said our nation on a
path of freedom and opportunity
from the very first day of this
administration
okay so all trump has to do so the
question of this campaign just like the
question of the last campaign
is who voters are focused on when they
go into the voting booth
or when they mail in their mail in
ballot as the case may be so in 2016
the great myth is that people were
thinking about trump when they cast
their ballot the truth is they're
thinking about hillary and how much they
didn't like hillary clinton
and that is why voters who didn't like
either hillary or trump voted
overwhelmingly for trump well in 2020
the same question applies are people
thinking about biden or are they
thinking about trump
when they go into the voting booth right
now they're overwhelmingly thinking
about trump but
if biden continues to gaff and if he
selects someone radical as his vp
that could seriously change it could
also change if president trump would
tone it down a little bit and be
concerted in his actual approach to his
own campaign
that is why it seems like just another
foolish move for the president to decide
that he is going to give his nomination
acceptance speech
from the white house which raises all
sorts of questions about the legality of
are you allowed to use taxpayer
resources in order to campaign this way
yesterday president trump dismissed
legal questions on accepting the
nomination directly from the white house
an unprecedented move
senator john soon questioned whether or
not that's actually legal given the
hatch act
is this something that you would get
clearance for john did
the republican john okay well
it is legal uh there is no hatch act
because it doesn't pertain to the
president
but if i use the white house we save
tremendous amounts of money for the
government
in terms of security traveling if we go
to
another state or some other location
the amount of money is you know very
enormous so
that's something to consider also yeah
i i the kind of backhanded slap at john
thune as though john thune is doing
something wrong by pointing out that
typically
american presidents don't conduct openly
political campaign speeches from the
white house
trump is wrong about this nancy it gives
it gives democrats room to run it's just
again political malfeasance here is
nancy pelosi
saying trump can't do that he can't do
that you can't do that i mean i
you you would be very surprised i think
at the
fact that when you're at the white house
you're talking about policy invest
you're not talking politics
we never did
you would have a limited reference as it
applied to
our civic life as terms of politics but
you don't talk politics in the white
house
you don't talk politics under the dome
of the capitol
except perhaps a reference to it but not
an event
you don't have political events in the
capitol you don't have political events
in the white house
now i'm just going to point out that
five minutes ago she was kneeling
wearing kente cloth on the floor of the
capitol
with the other democrats so you know
look trump is always saying that the
quiet part out loud namely the politics
obviously infuses the white house
obviously infuses halls of congress and
all the rest but is it a good precedent
do we actually want democrats doing this
sort of thing from the white house
probably not is it a smart political
move i don't think it's a smart
political move either
side notes can we please have a class of
politicians who speak english
my goodness we need to start teaching
english as the first language because
pelosi doesn't speak english
trump sometimes speaks english joe biden
doesn't
even speak human language anymore it's
all very weird in just a second we're
gonna get to
the chief line of attack for joe biden
because the chief line of attack in
favor of joe biden right now
is all kovitz stuff and this ties into
the coveted policies that are currently
being
pursued we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that it'd be nice if you never had to go
to the post office ever again wouldn't
it i mean post office does great things
but wouldn't it be nice if you could get
all the services
of the us postal service directly from
your home luckily
there is stamps.com thousands of small
business owners have discovered the
benefits of stamps.com
in recent months they've been able to
keep their businesses running and avoid
the crowds at the post office all from
their own computers with stamps.com you
can print and post it john demand and
avoid going to the post office you'll
save money with discounted rates you
can't even get at the post office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62
no residential surcharges here at daily
wear we've been using stamps.com since
2017.
no more wasting our time stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need
directly to your computer in the comfort
of your home or your office whether
you're a small business
sending invoices or an online seller
shipping out products or just working
from home you need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer print official
us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it like i said with
stamps.com you get great discounts as
well five cents off every stamp and up
to 62
off usps and ups shipping rates right
now my listeners get a special offer
it includes a four week trial plus free
postage and
a digital skill with no long-term
commitment just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page
type in code shapiro that is stamps.com
enter shapiro at the top of the homepage
for the special deal okay so the
democratic campaign against
president trump is now basically about
one issue and one issue only
and that is his handling of covet you
know his personality was always going to
be an issue because
his personality is an issue it's very
off-putting to many suburban women
it's very off-putting to to certain
members of minority groups for example
but that was always going to be an issue
it didn't matter because trump was
probably going to win if the economy was
as good as it was back in january or
february well now that covet is hit
the big issue has become coveted and
that means that the biden campaign
has to play it as though trump totally
blew it on covid now the problem with
that is that everyone kind of blew it
uncovered there's no such thing as not
blowing it on kobit
we're seeing spikes all around the world
we are seeing
spikes in blue states now we are seeing
secondary waves in certain blue states
and yet the the notion that the going
mythology and narrative that's being
promoted is the blue states handled this
perfectly and the only person who
screwed this up was donald trump so joe
biden put out an ad in florida
featuring a couple from the villages
talking about how they can't visit their
grandkids and blaming trump for that
here's the ad it really is quite
scurrilous
roger and i decided that we wanted to
move to the villages we were ready to
retire we were both 60.
he was in the military i had the
business for 10 years
my husband and i are both concerned
about the virus and catching it
i know other people have things a lot
worse but we feel trapped here
because we can't go to be with the ones
that we love
my husband and i have been gifted with
two beautiful grandchildren
we try to see them as often as possible
and it's been
six months and it's way too long
and while i don't blame donald trump
for the virus i blame him for his lack
of action
and because of that we're sitting here
zooming or face timing with our
grandchildren instead of hugging and
kissing them
and that's hard joe biden knows that
every moment is precious i trust joe
biden to get this virus under control
i'm joe biden and i approve this message
i mean i'm sorry that's a disgusting
message you trust joe biden to get this
undercut how
how like seriously hell because nobody
has this under control
there are literally zero places on
planet earth where if you're a
grandparent
who is in a vulnerable health position
you should feel supremely comfortable
about
hugging your 10 year old 12 year old
grandkids this is this is a bizarro
world ad again the idea i don't blame
trump for the virus i blame him
for the fact that i can't visit my
grandkids question are people visiting
grandkids all over the world how's that
going
because it's not the answer is it's not
but again there's this mythology that's
been created by the media
it's been created by the democrats that
trump really blew this thing and i keep
asking people okay what is trump
supposed to do
like what do you want him to do and
people say things like national mass
mandate okay let's be real about this
where the virus is the hottest people
are wearing masks this has been true for
a very long time
it turns out that people were socially
distancing before the government told
them to do so
because overall people ourself are
self-driven and are self-perpetuating
and are not idiots
they're going to protect themselves but
what else is trump
he's supposed to ramp up the testing the
united states is doing more tests on a
per capita basis than virtually other
any other nation on earth we're doing
hundreds of thousands of tests every
single day
is there a delay in the results of the
tests sometimes there is sometimes
there's not
can we help with that sure should states
do a better job absolutely but what
would biden be doing that's any
different
i have no idea and nobody can explain
what he would be doing that is any
different
that ad is really gross i mean saying
that grandparents can't visit their
grandkids because of trump
weird i didn't hear andrew cuomo's name
anywhere in there or phil murphy from
new jersey i didn't hear his name
anywhere in there there's a headline
from politico by the way talking about
the success of new jersey and flattening
the curve
new jersey literally has the worst death
permian rate i think on planet earth
it's like 1789
deaths per million in in new jersey
so the me i mean i'm sorry the narrative
that donald trump is the one who blew
this i just
i don't get it i i don't understand it
meanwhile the social media giants are
cracking down on trump's comments
they're fact-checking them with alacrity
so both facebook and twitter removed
some comments that trump made on kovid
the problem is that trump was basically
right okay he
the language he used was inexact but as
per our usual arrangement
trump's inexact language masks something
fundamentally true we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about your safety and security
at home there are a thousand reasons why
protecting your home matters to you ring
has security products for every corner
of your home inside and out best of all
you can see it all in one simple app
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone
if somebody stops by or something's
going on ring will let you know it's
peace of mind
anytime and knowing that your home is
protected whatever you call home ring
has everything you need to protect it
see and speak to whomever is at your
door from anywhere with video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with
easy to install door and outdoor cams
protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
home whole home security system
you can easily install yourself we use
ring devices on our property all the
time got to keep track of my wild and
crazy kids
my ring devices make me feel safe to
make my wife feel safe which is the most
important thing
and they make sure that my kids are in
fact safe get a special offer on the
ring
welcome kit at ringgit.com it comes with
the ring of video doorbell 3 and the
chime pro it's the perfect way
to start your ring experience plus free
two-day shipping go to ring.com
that is ring.com go check them out right
now ring.com
and get that special offer on the ring
welcome kit
okay so facebook and twitter removed
some comments that trump made about
covet
uh the the suggestion of course was that
trump had done something deeply deeply
wrong what exactly did they remove
well it was a clip of president trump
talking
in a phone interview about children and
he says if you look at children children
are almost
and i would say almost say definitely
but almost immune from this disease
and they removed that clip from facebook
and twitter
why because they said that it was
inaccurate it was in violation of
twitter rules on cover 19 misinformation
said a twitter spokeswoman
by the way twitter's a twitter
spokesperson came out and said that as
well
this that spokesperson happened to be a
former press secretary for kamala harris
if you wonder whether big tech is biased
depends on the company but um twitter is
using a former kamala harris aide
to shut down trump tweets and then
explain it and here's the reality
kids may not be immune to covenant 19
they do obtain cloven 19.
kids aren't dying of it they're not the
number of kids who are dying from covet
is a fraction of a percent a fraction of
a fraction of a percent
it is a tiny number of children who have
died from this like we're still talking
in the mid double digits
last i checked in the united states kids
who had died of coven 19 far
far less than nearly any other disease
you can name in the united states
so is trump totally wrong no they're
just taking that down so they can claim
that he's that he's putting out
misinformation
now meanwhile again trump's getting
blamed for everything bad that's
happening on planet earth
but let's be real about this things are
not great everywhere according to the uk
daily mail
second wave is striking europe spain
reintroduces lockdown greece sees
worrying rising cases the virus is more
active in germany amid warnings france
could quote
lose control at any moment according to
the uk daily mail a second wave of cover
19 appears to be striking europe
forcing spain to reimpose lockdowns in
cases spiking to a three-month high
in greece the head of germany's doctors
union has declared the country is
already in the midst of the second wave
because people have flouted
social distancing rules well this is
perfectly predictable you can't people
keep people locked down
forever like for literally years at a
time it's not a thing that you can do
instead you're going to have to at some
point allow people who are young and
healthy to go out there and if they get
it they get it
that is fact what sweden is doing in
sweden which remember until five minutes
ago was the bad guy
sweden has basically flattened the curve
it looks like sweden may have reached
her immunity is what it actually looks
like
meanwhile in other countries they got a
problem in fact
it seems pretty obvious what's happening
here italy has not seen a second uptick
why hasn't italy seen a second uptick
because they got nailed
basically here is the rule if it burned
through your population maybe you're
done if it has not burned through your
population you probably are not done
spain saw 8 500 new cases over the
weekend an all-inclusive resort in
majorca was shut down
two towns north of madrid have been put
under strict lockdown as well
finland today announced that it plans to
reintroduce recommendations to work from
home whenever possible
by august 1st finland's cases had risen
by more than 300 in two weeks
that ron desantis that governor of
florida can't believe he's also governor
of finland donald trump
obviously blowing it over in finland
he's blowing it over in france as well
authorities in france grappling with a
sharp increase in fresh cases which has
seen more than 7 7000 new infections
within the last week
as well as the rise in the number of
people being treated for covet 19
in the icu around 1200 new cases are
being reported per day two weeks ago
the rolling average was 719.
meanwhile in germany they're seeing an
uptick as well some 730 cases have been
reported each day on average this week
against the 460 being recorded per day
about two weeks ago
so the second wave is in fact hitting
europe it really is kind of the first
wave
it really is more the first wave because
the first wave basically
just got a little bit squished and
delayed
basically everything just got delayed
meanwhile
sweden seems to be coming out the other
end of this according to newsweek
as of sunday the latest death rate in
sweden death for 100 000 people was
reported
to be 56.4 the figure is lower than that
reported in the uk 69.6 spain 60.88 and
italy
according to the latest report sunday by
johns hopkins university
the uk currently has the world's first
fourth highest death toll spain and
italy
where the former two european countries
hit worse by the outbreak
sweden's latest case fatality ratio
that's the portion of deaths compared to
total cases
was reported to be about 7.1 percent
that figure is more than half the
percentage
reported in the uk half that of italy in
belgium and nearly half that of france
the reason being that a lot of young
people are getting it in sweden and it's
burned through some of the young
population
and now they're basically done sweden's
seven day rolling average daily new
cases
has been mostly declining since as far
back as april 16th when the average was
at 99
the average dropped to two two average
daily new deaths on august 2nd
according to worldometer new infections
for 100 000 people in sweden reported in
the past 14 days
has dropped some 46 percent compared to
that reported in the 14 days prior
meanwhile spain france germany belgium
the netherlands each spiking
between 58 and 206 in new cases
new cases in denmark norway and finland
all the other places that supposedly
handled it better than sweden
they've also seen their percentages
increasing at around
three times the percentage drop in new
cases seen in sweden in the past
two weeks so what that sort of says is
it looks like sweden may have beat this
thing it may look like it's over in
sweden
anders technell the chief epidemiologist
at sweden's public health agency
noted last week we've cut down on
movement in society quite a lot we've
compared how much we travel in
scandinavian countries the decrease in
travel is the same in sweden as in the
neighboring countries
in many ways the voluntary measures we
put in place in sweden have been just as
effective as complete lockdowns in other
countries
in other words when you tell people
don't travel all that much people take
it pretty seriously
but the point here is that for all the
talk about how we know how to handle
this
and we just have to shut everything down
lock down this lock down that
sweden lockdown and sweden maybe the
smartest of all
sweden may be the smartest of all
speaking of which
even anthony fauci is now saying he
doesn't think that we're gonna have to
do another shutdown
and as i've said before the experts keep
kind of shouting lockdown at the same
time they're acknowledging that lockdown
is kind of a bad idea here's anthony
thatcher yesterday
i i don't think we have to go into
shutdown mode
sanjay i am you know i am cautiously
optimistic
i do have um
an abiding faith in in the american
spirit
and and i that's the reason why i i
invest the time and i love being on with
you at in any forum because
we can start talking about the science
and the more
we give a consistent message
the more people are going to start to
understand what we need to do
okay and everybody sort of understands
all that we can do which is social
distance where some mass that's about it
that's about it and then there are
experts who are just saying things that
don't make tons of sense
so for example ezekiel emanuel yesterday
he said we have to reduce the amount of
time kids
are spending with other kids why
seriously why
my kids are in camp right now they
should be in camp right now the reason
that they're at home today
is because they came down with some cold
symptoms so if they're
sick we isolate them and if they're not
sick we don't isolate them
and that's pretty much it because it
turns out the kid's giving this thing to
other kids
is not killing kids in fact there's a
study out of japan today
and it demonstrates that school closures
carried out in japan did not show any
mitigating effect
on the transmission of novel coronavirus
infection
again not a great shock schools are not
the chief transmission vectors here but
here ezekiel emanuel yesterday
saying we have to reduce the amount of
time kids are spending with other kids
doing things indoors has to be limited
you have to what's called
de-densify reduce the number of children
to allow physical
distancing you have to have face masks
for the older
children you have to not use the
cafeteria where crowding
can take place so you have to think
through every step of the
process and you know reduce the crowds
reduce the congestion
uh reduce time that kids spend with uh
other kids and teachers
okay well no you could also just you
know have younger teachers teaching the
young kids
but again lockdown has become the
all-purpose solution to all of this and
this is political because if lockdowns
are the all-purpose solution and trump
isn't saying lockdown then trump is the
bad guy
so some of this is just plainly
political eric garcetti was pushing this
yesterday eric garcetti our idiot mayor
here
in los angeles he said yesterday he is
going to shut off the power
to any place holding an unregistered
gathering or party
he's literally just going to cut off the
water power i have no idea how this is
possibly legal
this is also the same idiot eric
garcetti who's out there protesting
without a mask
in the middle of blm protests with a
bunch of other people without masks
meanwhile in new york city they've
announced that they're going to be
setting up quarantine checkpoints
so bill de blasio is saying that they're
going to announce ten thousand dollar
fines and checkpoints for any traveler
who
flouts the new york city quarantine
meanwhile he's not opening anything in
new york city so i'm not sure
why you why does he care about
quarantine when everything is still
locked down seriously like if
everybody's still in their house
and what exactly is he so worried about
here's bill de blasio saying something
that probably is also patently illegal i
have no idea how how bill de blasio has
the power to teach
to tell people who are coming in from
out of state that they have to
pay a fine or or lockdown or something
like i don't know how that's legally
possible
so starting today we're going to do
something new in new york city we will
have checkpoints
at key entry points to the city
travelers coming in from those states
will be given information about the
quarantine they will be reminded that it
is required not optional
they'll be reminded that failure to
quarantine is a violation
of state law and it comes with serious
penalties
fact under certain circumstances the
fines can be as high as 10 000
so this doesn't sound totalitarian at
all you come into the state of new york
you go
to new york city and what he's going to
shut down all the bridges in the tunnels
bane from batman like what what in the
world is going on here well
i will say one of my favorite things
about new york state politics is the gap
between andrew cuomo and bill de blasio
basically if de blasio takes a position
cuomo hates his gut
until he'll immediately take the reverse
position shockingly andrew cuomo is now
the voice of reason in new york
so andrew cuomo yesterday was telling
bill de blasio do not raise taxes on
people in new york city
and he was begging rich people to come
back to new york city because the tax
base is basically gone welcome to the
republican party andrew cuomo when
reality finally hits
i literally talk to people all day long
who are now in the hamptons house
who also lived here or in their hudson
valley house
or in their connecticut weekend house
and i say you got to come back money
coming back
we'll go to dinner i'll buy you a drink
come over i'll cook
they're not coming back right now and
then he says
one percent of the population is paying
50 of all the taxes welcome to the
republican party
governor andrew cuomo who's realizing
that raising taxes randomly
on high earners drives them out of major
cities and out of major states okay
interest
second we're going to get to the
continuing cultural battle over whether
america sucks or not oprah has now taken
aside a woman worth 2.6 billion dollars
who rose from abject poverty become one
of the most powerful people on earth she
says america blows we'll get to that in
just one second first
everybody needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds but before you drop hundreds of
bucks on a pair
check out the wireless earbuds from
raycon you already know raycon earbuds
start at about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market
and they sound just as amazing as the
other top audio brands you do know
their newest model the everyday e25
earbuds those are the best ones yet six
hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit
raycon's wireless earbuds they are so
comfortable they are perfect for
conference calls
for binging podcasts unlike some of your
other wireless options raycon earbuds
are stylish and discreet
no dangling wires no stems to distract
anybody during video calls now is the
time to get the latest and the greatest
from
raycon get 15 percent off your order
right now at buy recon dot com
slash ben that is b u i r a y c o n dot
com slash been for 15 percent off
those raycon wireless earbuds i'm
spending an awful lot of time on my
earbuds
these days i want them to fit my ear
perfectly and that's why i love my
raycons by raycon.com slash bandits buy
raycon
dot com slash pen for 15 off okay
we'll get to the cultural battles over
race and the nature of the country in
just one second first i need to tell you
about our most exclusive membership tier
over at the daily wire all access
all access membership it features behind
the scenes access to live streams
discussions with your podcast hosts me
included as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products
as part of that we launched our brand
new limited accounts collector's edition
baseball bat
in collaboration with pilbot back
pillbox bat company
only 100 bats were made they were
engraved with the individual number in
the order they were produced from 1-100
now here's the crazy part the bats were
only offered to all access members
they sold out in two days so if you
don't want to miss out on exclusive
products and offers
you should really join all access at the
daily wire you'll also get exclusive
access to live online discussions with
our hosts
writers and special guests along with
joining all access live that's our
exclusive live stream q as hosted every
night lastly
you get not one but two leftist tears
tumblers with your membership so
head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now at 20 percent off all access
with coupon code access
is a limited time membership so remember
dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access to get
20 off your membership
right now you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
all righty so meanwhile our cultural
battles continue a pace
and putting aside the insanity over
kovad and the presidential election
the deeper battles in the country
continue to be over the nature of
america and whether america is
fundamentally good or whether it
fundamentally is not
my book how to destroy america in three
easy steps on the new york times
bestseller list again this week
that book is all about this gap this gap
between people who believe that america
inherently sucks
and people who believe that america's
founding principles were good and
perfectly realized over time but
increasingly perfectly realized
over time in the former category people
who think american sucks are a great
many people
who have benefited inordinately from
america people
who grew up in abject poverty in the
direst of circumstances and have become
insanely powerful and wealthy
one of those people case a one would be
oprah winfrey oprah winfrey
her life story is truly an american
miracle i mean this is a person who was
in the worst circumstances in just
terrible personal circumstances
endemic poverty and she somehow makes
her way to be worth 2.6 billion dollars
she owns like half the island
of maui that didn't stop her yesterday
from denouncing america's white
privilege she says that if you're white
you have this privilege no matter what
here was oprah winfrey yesterday
white people there are white people who
are not as powerful
as the system of white people the caste
system that's
been put in place but they still
no matter where they are on the wrong
or the ladder of success they still have
their whiteness
oh well they still have their whiteness
i mean i i would trade my whiteness
right now for for oprah winfrey's well
that seems like a really really solid
deal
frankly in fact i would trade my
whiteness for like like
i don't care about my whiteness like i
think most people don't care very much
about the color of their skin
and if they do i think that they're
spending their time in life on the wrong
things
i mean i i don't see why your color of
your skin should define you it seems
like there are many many other
attributes about you as a character and
as a human being
that should define you but for oprah
winfrey she's now pushing this new book
called cast this is written by the same
person who suggested that there have
been only three durable cast systems in
world history
nazi germany the united states and india
which is patently crazy
cast unfortunately is a feature of a
wide variety of cultures and subcultures
all around the earth
and the notion that the united states
has a durable caste system today in 2020
is patently crazy it's insane
it's insane and nonetheless oprah
winfrey pushed that one yesterday as
well
and at this point you have to imagine
yourself what does she like does she
really believe that black americans
don't have any opportunity in a country
where she went from absolute poverty to
being one of the wealthiest people
on earth does she believe that she's the
only exception because she obviously is
not the average black income in the
united states is 58
000 a year the median household income
in the united states for black americans
is 41 000
a year black americans are richer than
any other
african origin people anywhere on earth
black canadians do not earn as much as
black americans black britishers do not
earn
as much as black americans black black
people in africa do not earn as much as
black americans
so the if the idea is that the united
states is uniquely terrible i'm just
wondering what the evidence is for the
united states being uniquely terrible
it could make that case when jim crow is
in place certainly obviously you can
make that case when slavery was in place
certainly and obviously
you can't make that case very well today
when we've had a two-term
black president of the united states
overwhelmingly elected
we have we've had black people in nearly
every powerful
position in the united states and
we ha which is great i mean that's a
good oh this is a good thing
i mean i don't like barack obama but it
says something good about our country
that
we elected a black man president of the
united states in a majority white
country
that's a pretty amazing thing that's
unprecedented in virtually all of world
history
but apparently apparently critical race
theory which is the theory that we can
all basically
be melted down into our into our racial
essentials
and so if you're white you're essential
is that you're privileged at the expense
of black people and if you're black
then you are racially essentialized into
victimhood at the hands of white
americans
and that that leads to the predictable
result that any disparity between black
and white
is the system at work so this is how you
get ibrahim kendi who literally says
this he literally says any inequality
between black and white
is attributable to the system you get
imbram kendi on msnbc suggesting that
when black people die at higher rates of
covet
that suggests that there is something
wrong with the society he's going to
have to explain
in which society black people are not
dying at higher rates than white people
literally across europe black people are
like i i do not understand what is his
control
in order to make this sort of claim it's
pretty far-reaching claim you have to
have a control group what's this control
group here
if the problem is coveted racial
disparities black people being two and a
half times more likely to die of
of of coke with 19 we need to realize
that it's not because there's something
wrong with black people
it's because there's something wrong
with our policies if there's something
wrong with society there's something
wrong with that
that black and brown people are more
likely to
have to essentially be essential workers
they can't work from home or
they're more likely to live in polluted
neighborhoods they're they're they're
less likely to have access to health
insurance or
or high quality care and and those are
systemic issues that that need to be
changed
now he's talking about class issues he's
not talking about race issues right
there are a lot of poor white people who
are working
a lot of poor white people live in
polluted neighborhoods but everything
boils down to racial essentialism the
problem is
that all this is incredibly
counterproductive so there's a study
that demonstrates pretty significant and
clearly that the sort of diversity
training where you hire robin deangelo
or ibram kennedy to tell all of your
white staffers how racist they are
that sort of training not only doesn't
work it causes an enormous amount of
racial tension there's a good piece over
at theconversation.com by amna khalid an
associate professor of history at
carleton college
and jay and jeffrey aaron snyder another
associate professor
over at carlson college all about
diversity training and here's what they
say in terms of reducing bias and
promoting equal opportunity
diversity training has failed
spectacularly according to the expert
assessment of sociologists frank dobbin
and alexander khalif
when david and kaleb evaluated the
impact of diversity training
at more than 800 companies over three
decades they found that the positive
effects are short-lived and that
compulsory training generates resistance
and resentment
a company is better off doing nothing
than mandatory diversity training kolov
concluded
some of the most popular training
approaches are of dubious value there's
evidence for example
introducing people to the most commonly
used readings about white privilege can
reduce
sympathy for poor whites especially
among social liberals actually what
those studies tend to show
is that social liberals don't feel
better about black people they just feel
worse about white people
there's also evidence that emphasizing
cultural differences across racial
groups can lead to an increased belief
in fundamental biological differences
among races which means the
well-intentioned efforts to celebrate
diversity
may in fact reinforce racial
stereotyping
the main beneficiaries of these people
are the diversity trainers themselves
who've been able to rake in oodles of
cash obviously
so if it doesn't work at companies how
do you think it works for a country
when you decide to re-educate the entire
country that america is a racially
essentialist caste system
when you suggest that every inequality
is a reflection of the evils of the
united states you think that's going to
result
in more anger or do you think that it's
going to result in a diverse new
tolerance
what do you think the answer is more
anger and also more stupidity
this is one of my favorite stories ever
it's a pretty spectacular story
mashable reports it but it was all over
the internet yesterday
quote what first seemed to be a tragic
story a professor was forced to work in
person and later died of covet
now seems to be a strange hoax multiple
reports and information uncovered from
online sleuths
suggest the twitter account sciencing by
who claims to be a bisexual professor
of native american descent may have
actually been fake it appears it was the
creation of beth anne mclaughlin the
head of a group called me too stem which
aims to fight sexual harassment in
scientific fields
in june the account sciencing by claims
on twitter that her employer arizona
state university
forced her to deliver lectures in person
in april to 200 students which led her
to get coveted
on july 31st mclaughlin announced from
her twitter account
mick linero this that sciencing by had
died from covet 19.
but asu officials said it had no reports
of a faculty member dying from the
coronavirus and that it never employed a
professor matching
sciencing by's description the
university also closed its campus in
march so
it couldn't been classes in april asu
spokesperson katie paquette
told buzzfeed news we've been looking
into this for the last 24 hours and
cannot verify any connection with the
university
we've been in touch with several deans
and faculty members no one can identify
the account
or who might be behind it the account
had apparently tweeted for years
about their experiences as an indigenous
woman being lgbtq in academic circles
and more recently their long drawn out
suffering from covet 19.
lots of folks familiar with this
particular corner of science twitter
pointed out inconsistency with the
stories
including in now inaccessible instances
where they apparently used stock images
to accompany
apparent real-life experiences
mclaughlin denied she created sciencing
buy out of whole cloth
but did admit she had access to the
account she claimed that as far as she
knew
this account did die of covet 19. she
said she got that from a family contact
mclaughlin has reportedly declined to
reveal sciencing by's actual identity
and also said she had met her in real
life
after the alleged death mclaughlin
seemed to suggest they were in an
intimate relationship tweeting
looking at her side of the bed and
crying just a lot of crying i literally
can do nothing
this is not the first instance of
controversy surrounding mclaughlin a
march report from science magazine
detailed
at mclaughlin while hosting me too stem
allegedly sidelined people of color and
bullied volunteers
activists and fellow leaders in other
words this is a crazy lefty lady
who was using all of the trappings and
all the hallmarks of woke culture
in order to get ahead in order to
generate sympathy for an agenda that she
was pushing
that says something about where the
halls of power in america truly lie does
it not
you don't see a lot of people who are
seeking power attempting to ape
conservatives like pretend to be a
conservative you don't see that a lot
you don't see a lot of people who want
power attempting to be white
right that's not you don't have reverse
racial dolozos and that that is
an indicator of where power lies in a
society right during jim crow it was a
fairly common
and and horrific thing i mean
horrifically that anybody felt they
needed to do this
that light-skinned black people would
sometimes attempt to pass for white
right this is a very very
there's been a number of famous novels
on this particular topic because
white was power for a lot of american
history
well now there are not a lot of black
people masquerading as white people but
you will see a rachel doloz all
attempting to be black and here you will
see
a professor pretending to be a bisexual
native american woman
the halls of power are replete with the
diversity crew
and that is where people are attempting
to pander in order to get ahead
which says something about where america
stands doesn't say that america is
deeply intolerant
of diversity it says precisely the
opposite that we are so militantly in
favor of diversity that we'll swallow
any stupid thing put forth so long as
you slap a diversity label on it
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow
with a with more content or later today
with a couple
additional hours of content you're
listening to the bench shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
joe biden forgets about his cognitive
decline billionaire oprah winfrey tells
poor white people that they have a whole
lot of privilege
and millard fillmore gets cancelled 170
years
after the compromise of 1850. shocking
shocking stuff plus the mailbag
check it out on the michael knowles show